you hear a lot of different stories
about all these mob families when you
got five different families out there
like New York ad you run up the problems
you've been a tough guy since you were a
kid coming up when I grew up my father
was a real tough guy he was a driver a
wheelman and a killer and a killer
of course it bothered me I think about
the faces all the things how do you
process it it happened when you're
sleeping done and it's over with there's
nothing I could do I can't you can't
bring him back he's then clean your
dirty laundry now I didn't fall out of a
tree I've heard that term used too many
times if you've seen the movie cuz you
know the guys had the vice and come on I
didn't do that well let's say Tony
thought it roll when you use that word
that's like snitching is the same thing
exact we got it we got a big robbery it
was a bank we didn't count the money as
we were taking it out with Trude in
duffel bags I was 18 years old I had
never seen that much money in my life
then the bad news came that's when I
really learned about the Chicago Outfit
irregardless of what you Aaron this is
true story
you
[Music]
you